Prof: Well,
today we turn to politics and
the structures of power under
the early Tudors.
On the 22nd of August 1485,
Henry Tudor,
who was then the Earl of
Richmond, defeated and killed
King Richard III at the Battle
of Bosworth Field,
a battlefield which is located
in central England in the county
of Leicestershire,
and was crowned upon the
battlefield with the crown which
was found in the King's tent,
and became king as Henry VII.
Now, in fact,
his claim to the throne was
somewhat weak.
He was descended on his
father's side from the widow of
King Henry V,
who had married Henry's
grandfather after the King's
death,
but that didn't establish a
direct claim to the throne.
His claim came principally
through his mother,
Lady Margaret Beaufort,
who was a descendant of the
fourteenth-century king Edward
III.
Nevertheless,
weak though his claim was,
Henry was the last of the
claimants of the Lancastrian
House and he took the throne on
the behalf of that particular
group in English politics,
which I'll explain later.
In the twenty-four years
following his seizure of the
throne he made it his business
first of all to hang on to it,
secondly to assert his
authority as best he could,
and thirdly to pass on the
crown to his son,
Henry VIII, who succeeded him
in 1509--
and by doing so he founded a
new dynasty,
the Tudor dynasty.
Well, today I want to look at
some of the early stages of that
dynasty and in particular to
introduce the structures of
political power and authority as
they were exercised under Henry
VII and in the early part of the
reign of Henry VIII,
and by doing so to show how
they managed to establish and
consolidate the new regime.
Now by "power,"
of course,
I mean that I'm concerned with
the capacity to secure
compliance and obedience on the
part of others.
By "authority I mean
legitimate power:
those forms of power and its
manifestations which were deemed
by most,
if not all, people to be
legitimate,
to be binding,
to put you under obligation to
obey.
There were many sources of such
power and authority:
economic, ideological,
political, military,
and so forth.
And to a considerable degree,
as we'll see,
they all overlapped and
reinforced one another,
but taken together they
comprised the polity of the time
as contemporaries described it;
the polity, a system of
established government and rule.
Now in approaching this kind of
subject it's currently
fashionable amongst political
historians of this period to
speak of the need for what they
call a new political history as
distinct from the old
constitutional history.
It's a central theme in John
Guy's book, The Tudor
Monarchy, from which
several of our key readings are
taken.
By this people mean a political
history which is less narrowly
focused upon the development of
the institutions of government.
That was for a long time the
really central concern of
historians of this period.
They were very focused on the
development of particular
institutions.
Instead, now people are
recommending a concern instead
with the changing contexts and
dynamics of political life and
in particular the social and
ideological context of politics.
Well, I'm very sympathetic to
that shift of perspective.
I can still remember only too
well the old constitutional
history in its heyday.
As a student I sat sometimes at
the feet of the great professor
G.R.
Elton who was famous for
declaring that in getting to
grips with the structures of
government it was essential that
students should learn to be
bored.
>
And when he could deliver a
whole lecture on one of the
seals used in Tudor government
and the purposes for which the
seal was employed and so forth,
he was a man who sometimes
practiced what he preached
>
But even if the approach has
changed somewhat over the years
it's still essential that we do
get to grips with the
institutions through which
government authority was
exercised.
They provided the forum for
political competition and they
shaped the way
that--that--political
competition was conducted.
So historians today are very
much concerned with political
culture.
I've offered a definition of
that on your handout,
but political culture involves
also institutions;
they're part of it.
So we'll start by running over
some of the aspects of the
institutional structure under
the early Tudors and then look
at political society and then at
how political society could be
animated and controlled and the
authority of government
sustained by the effective use
of all of these institutions
under the early Tudors.
Now the essential points about
some of these institutions are
laid out on your handout,
so I'll just quick march
through some of them to briefly
introduce them.
Right.
Well, in 1500 England was
already a very old and,
by the standards of the day,
a quite intensively and
uniformly governed monarchy.
It had existed as a single
monarchy for 600 to 700 years
already.
The origins of its high degree
of centralization probably go
back to the late Saxon kings but
in particular to the time of the
Norman conquest of the eleventh
century and its consequences,
but that's not our business
today.
Suffice to say that by 1500
many of the central institutions
of royal government were very
old and had been established by
the initiatives of medieval
kings and reflected the
relationships which they had
hammered out over time with
their subjects.
Above all with their most
powerful subjects,
the nobility,
those who served the king but
could also on occasion oppose
him and had done so many times
in the past.
The king was of course at the
very center of the polity.
He was described by one
sixteenth-century constitutional
writer,
Sir Thomas Smith,
as being "the life,
the head, and the authority of
all things that be done in this
realm of England."
The principal functions of the
king were seen to be those of:
keeping the peace and defending
the realm;
maintaining the law and the
administration of justice;
and upholding the church:
a relatively limited set of
functions compared to modern
government.
And to achieve those ends the
king enjoyed a variety of
powers.
He enjoyed what were thought of
as his ordinary powers exercised
within the framework of the law,
but in time of emergency he
might also exercise residual
absolute powers which could go
beyond the normal boundaries of
the law.
Well, English kings already had
a very high notion of their
dignity and their sovereign
authority.
From the fourteenth century
onwards they very often
represented--
in the coinage--they were
represented wearing what's known
as the "imperial
crown."
That's a crown which is
enclosed at the top usually with
a cross;
an enclosed crown.
It was meant to symbolize the
fact that they recognized no
authority higher than themselves
save God alone.
And though the authority of the
pope was exercised within the
kingdom over the church,
agreements which had been
reached and statutes which had
been passed in the fourteenth
century meant that in practice
in making appointments in the
church the pope usually acted on
the advice and in consultation
with the king.
They didn't override his
authority.
So a monarchy of considerable
dignity claiming a sovereignty
represented in the imperial
crown.
But high as the king's dignity
was,
England was also,
as one contemporary jurist,
John Fortescue,
put it, a dominium
politicum et regale--
he phrase is there on your
handout--
which meant that royal
authority was supreme--
that's the regale
part--but it was also sustained
and restrained by certain
political expectations,
certain constitutional
institutions.
First, kings were expected to
take advice.
They were expected to be guided
by counsel, by the counsel of
their leading subjects.
They ruled with the advice of a
variety of councils.
Occasionally,
a great council of the leading
nobility could be called,
especially when advice and
support was needed in the making
of some major decision.
Henry VII called such councils
of his leading noblemen on a
number of occasions.
More usually,
for day-to-day administration,
the king was advised by a
smaller council which attended
his person on a day-to-day basis
and handled the executive
business of government.
Some of its members were great
noblemen, but very often their
position in the council was one
which was largely honorific.
They tended on the whole to
proffer their advice to the king
informally and occasionally when
they were in attendance at
court.
For the most part,
for example,
Henry VII's day-to-day council
consisted in its principal
members not of the great nobles
of the kingdom,
but of great members of the
church,
notably Cardinal John Morton,
who was one of his closest
advisers in the early stages of
his rule,
and in addition a number of
lawyers and professional
administrators,
those who are sometimes
described as 'men of business',
the nucleus of a kind of royal
bureaucracy.
So the king was expected to
take counsel.
In addition,
he was restrained by the law,
the 'common law' of
England--described as common
because it extended over the
whole realm.
The king's writ ran everywhere
in legal matters.
The common law had grown up
over centuries by custom and by
precedent.
It was administered in the
king's name.
All legal writs began with the
king's title.
It was administered in his
name, though under normal
circumstances he was expected to
operate within the constraints
of the law.
The administration of the law,
the provision of justice,
and the redress of grievances,
the means of settling disputes
peacefully,
was one of the principal
functions of royal government.
Occasionally,
the king might still sit
himself in judgment.
One of the courts which became
most feared under Henry VII was
the king's Court of Star
Chamber,
which met in a chamber of the
palace of Westminster which
happened to be decorated on the
roof with stars,
the Star Chamber.
It was effectively the king's
council sitting as a law court
and the king might on occasion
be personally present,
but for the most part the
principal law courts operated
outside the royal household.
They sat permanently in
Westminster,
in Westminster Hall that still
stands besides--
beside--the houses of
Parliament, and they were
staffed by royal justices.
The names of the principal
courts are on your handout.
There was a Court of King's
Bench which dealt principally
with criminal matters,
the Court of Common Pleas which
dealt principally with civil
cases,
and the Chancery,
the Court of the Lord
Chancellor.
That court was a little unusual
in that it was not a common-law
court;
it was a court of equity.
Equity.
That meant that in cases where
the common law didn't provide a
remedy principles of natural
justice might be administered by
the chancellor,
and for that reason the
chancellor was sometimes
described as being the
conscience of the king,
could provide a remedy based on
natural justice when the common
law did not.
Okay.
In addition to the central
courts, the king also exercised
justice by commission.
Twice a year royal judges left
Westminster and went out to
ride--
to literally ride--six circuits
going from county town to county
town where they heard cases
arising--
civil cases and criminal cases
in the provinces.
Those were the assize courts,
the riding of circuits by royal
justices.
And in addition the king
exercised justice through the
commission of the peace.
In each county some leading
gentlemen were appointed as
justices of the peace
commissioned to deal with
crimes,
usually petty crimes,
and other administrative
matters arising.
They met in a court called
Quarter Sessions because it met
four times a year.
Counsel and law came together
in another great institution
that must be mentioned,
Parliament: the periodic
meeting of the king,
the nobility who had the right
to sit in the House of Lords,
and representatives of the
commons of the kingdom.
The House of Lords consisted of
the leading lay and church
nobility of the realm summoned
by a personal writ to attend.
In 1510 for example,
when Parliament met there were
100 of them, fifty laymen,
fifty great men of the church.
The House of Commons consisted
of a gathering of two
representatives for each
county--
they were known as the
"Knights of the
Shire"--
and two representatives from
each city which had the
parliamentary franchise;
they were known as burgesses.
The city of London provided an
exception.
It had four members because of
its size.
Now theoretically the members
who came for the counties were
elected by freeholders who had
land to the value of forty
shillings,
though in fact contested
elections were very rare.
Generally, the elite of the
counties would get together and
choose from amongst their
numbers who would represent
them.
They were selected rather than
elected.
The urban franchise might vary.
In some cities all householders
had the vote.
In others the choice of a
member for Parliament was
restricted to a small oligarchy
of the leading citizens.
Parliament, then,
represented the whole realm and
it had two great functions,
long established.
First of all,
only Parliament could make
statutes: new laws which could
override or modify common law
custom.
So the legislative sovereignty
of the realm lay in Parliament
where the king,
the lords and the commons acted
together.
Bills proposing new laws were
presented,
they were read and debated in
each of the houses before being
passed and passed on to the king
for his consent or his veto.
Now if all that sounds rather
familiar, this is where it comes
from.
Secondly, Parliament could
grant taxes, which from the
fourteenth century required the
consent of the House of Commons.
It was essential that the
Commons gave their consent to
any tax bill passing through
Parliament.
Okay.
One last word on institutions
and that concerns finance.
The king was expected to
"live of his own."
That's the phrase they used,
"to live of his own."
That meant he was expected to
live on the revenues of the
royal land holdings,
the customs dues and other dues
which were due to him as feudal
overlord of the kingdom,
and for all normal purposes
that should provide for all his
expenses.
The collection and the
disbursement of royal revenues
was handled by an institution
called the Exchequer,
at Westminster.
At least that was so in theory
since some late medieval kings
took to handling financial
business in a more intimate
setting within their own
household.
This was known as "chamber
finance,"
because they would deal with
these matters in the king's own
lodgings or chamber.
Henry VII, who was a notorious
workaholic and also extremely
tight in financial matters,
actually personally went over,
checked and initialed every
page of the chamber accounts to
check his financial situation.
Reliance on taxation was rare.
Taxes would be voted by
Parliament for extraordinary
circumstances and would then be
collected and returned to the
Exchequer.
So for the most part the king
lives of his own;
periodically taxes would be
granted for special reasons.
Okay.
That's a quick run through some
of the principal institutions of
day-to-day administration of
royal government,
but of course administration is
not synonymous with government.
If we want to understand the
structures of power we need to
look beyond this to the larger
political society within which
these institutions functioned,
or sometimes failed to function.
Obviously, the monarch stood at
the head of the structure of
power.
This is still an age of
personal monarchy and the
personalities of individual
monarchs colored and gave a
particular texture to particular
reigns.
Henry VII was a man who seems
by all accounts of him to have
been of a cold,
somewhat detached,
calculative,
suspicious, temperament.
His son, Henry VIII,
in contrast,
was energetic,
muscular, vain;
a mixture of largesse on the
one hand but prone to bursts of
terrifying wrath on the other,
and the personalities of
different kings gave something
of the flavor to their reigns.
Henry VII for example was only
twenty-eight when he won the
crown at Bosworth Field.
He was only fifty-two when he
died, and yet it's been said we
never think of him as a young
man.
His personality was such that
one doesn't think of him that
way, in contrast to his
flamboyant son,
the young Henry VIII.
The various institutions of
government of course embodied
the authority of the monarch.
They gave stability and
continuity,
but the actual exercise of
power and the maintenance of the
authority of government depended
very much upon the personality
of the king and the way in which
the kings interacted with
various important groups of
people,
communities of interest within
the realm.
By 1500, there already existed
a relatively broad political
society which was involved in
government in one way or
another.
Most ranks of society down to
the principal citizens of the
towns or even the leaders of
village society were involved in
government in one way or another
except perhaps the very poor,
who were described by Sir
Thomas Smith as being born
"to be ruled and not to
rule others."
But of course if many people
participated in one way or
another in the exercise of royal
power, some people mattered a
great deal more than others.
And those who mattered most
were of course the nobility and
the gentry and their
counterparts,
the leaders of the church.
And the crucial relationship
within the whole structure of
authority was that between the
king and his central officers
and those members of the social
elites who governed the
localities.
It was those elites who
constituted the political nation
proper,
and when historians of this
period talk about the political
nation it's primarily those
people they're talking about.
The nobility were absolutely
vital in two very obvious ways
which were interconnected.
First of all,
by virtue of their enormous
landed possessions they were the
natural rulers of the provinces.
Social power and political
power in the realm intersected.
The Percy family,
the earls of Northumberland,
held absolutely vast lands in
the north of England alongside
the Scottish border where they
had the responsibility of
defending the border against the
Scots.
Indeed, they still hold them.
The--they virtually ruled that
part of the north from their
principal castles at Alnwick and
Warkworth, both of which still
stand.
If you've seen a Harry Potter
film, you've seen Alnwick
Castle.
It was used to shoot parts of
those movies.
The Percys were based there and
it was said,
with only a little
exaggeration,
that in that part of the
kingdom they "knew no
prince but a Percy."
Secondly, the powers of
lordship which were conferred by
these great estates translated
into military power.
The king had no standing army.
Henry VII was unusual in that
he had a small group of royal
guards permanently available,
the Yeomen of the Guard;
otherwise, though,
there was no standing army.
In time of war the king relied
upon the nobility coming in to
support him with their armed
retainers and servants,
and each great lord had his
'affinity' as it was called,
his affinity of retainers:
men bound to his service by
ties of personal loyalty and
often by formal contract.
They wore his badge or his
livery and they were expected to
follow him when called upon.
People as humble as farm
tenants in some parts of the
kingdom still had to keep a
horse and arms as part of the
conditions of holding their
farms from the gentry and
nobility.
In the north for example that
was commonly the case,
and when called upon by the
earls of Northumberland or the
earls of Westmoreland,
who dominated what's now the
Lake District,
they would come in,
especially for service on the
border.
To give one example of the
importance of the military power
of the nobility:
in 1536 at the outbreak of the
rebellion against the
Reformation known as the
Pilgrimage of Grace the Earl of
Shrewsbury,
who was based in the north
Midlands,
was able to mobilize no fewer
than 3,000 men in only six days.
The rebellion had broken out in
Yorkshire;
Shrewsbury was here.
The fact that he could mobilize
3,000 men so quickly was
absolutely crucial because he
was able to move north and to
halt the rebel advance,
to shadow the rebels until a
larger royal force could be
mustered.
In contrast,
his friend and former companion
in arms, Lord Darcy,
based in South Yorkshire,
sympathized with the rebels and
failed to move.
He sat on his hands for a while
and then eventually joined the
rebels.
He should have been mustering
his troops to stop them.
That's why such men were
crucial.
Darcy didn't act because he was
out of sympathy with royal
policy in religion.
Shrewsbury acted and saved the
day.
Such men were vital.
Having said all of this,
I must be careful not to
exaggerate.
The nobility were rich and
powerful but they didn't have
fully independent jurisdictions
of their own where the king's
authority didn't run.
Some of the great nobility of
continental Europe enjoyed that
kind of power.
So did some of those of
Scotland in this period.
In England such jurisdictions
had existed in the past but they
had mostly gradually fallen into
the crown's hand and been
retained.
As a result,
English nobles depended
ultimately for their power upon
grants of royal office.
Their local authority was
granted to them by the king.
King Edward IV,
who ruled between 1461 and
1483, had ruled very largely by
parceling out spheres of
influence to the great nobility.
His system of government has
been described as being somewhat
like the mob in the way that
each of the great nobles had his
quasi-independent sphere of
influence.
But that was an anomalous
situation.
For the most part the nobles
depended upon royal authority
formally granted.
Nevertheless,
they still mattered a great
deal.
Maintaining authority over them
was absolutely vital.
In the middle of the fifteenth
century,
King Henry VI had failed to do
so, leading first of all to
rivalry and factionalism amongst
his nobles and eventually to a
bid by one of them,
the Duke of York,
to overthrow him because York
had a rival claim to the throne.
That led to the on-and-off
civil wars which ran between
1450 and 1485 usually described
as the Wars of the Roses.
Now the feuding of the
fifteenth-century Wars of the
Roses had taken out a number of
exceptionally over-mighty
subjects amongst the nobility,
but in the reign of Henry VII
there were still a dozen or so
who really mattered and not just
in the north or along the Welsh
borders,
which were areas of insecurity,
but in the very heart of the
kingdom.
In East Anglia the dukes or
Norfolk, the Howards,
were paramount.
In Kent, Lord Abergavenny was
paramount.
In the west,
the Marquis of Exeter,
the Courtney family,
were paramount.
They still nurtured their
affinities of retainers,
they still enjoyed great
prestige as regional leaders,
and they still adhered to an
aristocratic code that certainly
stressed loyalty,
honor and service to the king.
But nonetheless they could be
very haughty,
very touchy,
they assumed their right to
rule,
they assumed their right to be
consulted,
and they could be very
dangerous indeed if they were
slighted.
No Tudor king was ever likely
to forget that in 1485 at the
Battle of Bosworth the Stanleys,
William Stanley,
Lord Derby, and his brother,
Thomas Stanley,
brought their forces and then
sat on the hill waiting to see
which way the battle between the
claimant,
Henry Tudor,
and King Richard III would go.
When they decided that it
looked like Tudor was gaining
the upper hand they joined in on
his side leading ultimately to
the death of Richard III in a
desperate last charge to try to
break through.
That's what had happened on the
day that Henry came to the
throne.
He was unlikely to forget that
in his dealings with his
nobility.
So then, how did the early
Tudors handle their
relationships with the various
institutions and groups on whom
the effectiveness of their rule
depended?
I think one can suggest four
ways.
They did it by propaganda,
by patronage,
by consultation and,
when necessary,
by simple coercion.
Two P's, two C's:
propaganda, patronage,
consultation,
and coercion.
At this point in time,
propaganda was perhaps the
least important of the four but
it was not insignificant.
Great stress was laid in royal
proclamations and ceremonial and
symbolism upon the divine nature
of royal authority,
on the fact that the king was
ordained by God and his subjects
had a religious duty of
obedience.
Henry VII was very careful
early in his reign to obtain the
recognition of the pope.
He further bolstered his claim
to the crown by marrying the
daughter of his predecessor,
King Edward IV,
uniting the houses of Lancaster
and York through that marriage,
adding to his legitimacy.
From the reign of Henry VII
onwards into the reign of his
son,
the past, the public memory of
the past,
was to some extent remodeled
into an exaggerated picture of
the horrors which had attended
the breakdown of royal authority
in the Wars of the Roses.
They elaborated the myth of
Richard III as a kind of monster
king.
I mean, true enough he was no
sweetie, but he was not the
crook-backed monster portrayed
for example in Shakespeare's
history plays.
Historians were commissioned to
write appropriate histories
celebrating the Tudor dynasty.
Polydore Vergil,
an Italian humanist,
was brought in to write one
history in Latin.
Edward Hall produced another
history in English entitled
The Union of the Illustrious
Families of Lancaster and
York, which sustained
the Tudors' claim to the throne.
Shakespeare's history plays of
course reflect very much this
Tudor interpretation of history.
The image of royalty was
cultivated in a kind of theater
of majesty.
Tight as he was with his
finances, Henry VII never forgot
the importance of having a
magnificent court and sumptuous
clothing.
The pageantry of the court was
magnificent.
Great tournaments were held.
Great buildings were erected,
perhaps the greatest of which,
Henry VII's chapel at
Westminster Abbey where he's
buried, still stands today.
Under the reign of Henry VIII
portraiture, royal portraiture,
began to emerge as a means of
royal propaganda.
Henry VIII always had himself
represented as something more
than human.
In the National Portrait
Gallery in London you can see
the cartoon which survives of a
great painting of Henry and the
Tudor line which was once on the
walls of his palace of
Whitehall.
Henry himself is shown much
larger than life size,
dwarfing all those around him.
He was indeed a big man but
he's represented as even larger
than life.
You are probably familiar with
the Holbein portraits of Henry
standing, arms on hips,
gigantic shoulders padded out
with his doublet.
That kind of image of the king
is the one that dominates our
memory and it was meant to
dominate those who saw his
portraits.
It's an image that is so
familiar to people in England
that it was actually used to
sell potato chips
>
a few years ago.
There was a brand of potato
chips--they're no longer sold so
this is not product
placement--called Tudor
Crisps--we call them crisps in
England.
Henry VIII on the packet
glowering out as you had your
potato chips.
Of course, he was a king known
for his hearty eating.
>
The nobles themselves of course
imitated all of this.
The theater of the great
extended to them.
Take a look in the Yale gallery
of British art where you'll see
some of--
well, we'll go there later in
the term to look at some of the
power portraits,
as they're called:
the calm, proud faces of these
people staring down from the
walls.
Well, the main impact of
portraiture and so forth was on
the members of the elite
themselves.
They were the ones who were
likely to see these paintings,
but for a larger audience there
were processions;
there were royal progresses
where the king would travel
around an area in a magnificent
procession, staying in the
houses of his principal
subjects.
There were royal entries to the
cities accompanied by great
ritual, pageants,
display, and everywhere the
royal badge was displayed.
It's an interesting topic,
the politics of display,
the art and architecture of
power, and a great deal has been
written about it.
If it interests you,
I can recommend some reading.
Rather more significant than
propaganda of this type,
and in fact vitally
significant, was the use of
patronage,
the exercise of what they
called good lordship.
That involved the conferring on
significant subjects of honors
and prestige and material
benefits in return for their
loyal service.
After all, the interests of the
king and his great subjects were
not opposed.
The system ideally could be
utilized to the advantage of
both,
and so from Henry VII onwards
the Tudors were careful to build
up their own affinity,
their own loyal retainers.
Royal lands were used to this
end.
Those who had shown their
loyalty and who were trusted
would be granted stewardships of
royal lands where they would
share in the profits:
favorable leases,
the constableships of castles,
offices of profit,
and of course grants of local
authority which demonstrated the
king's trust and which conferred
honor and power within their
localities of prominence.
All of this was not only to the
personal benefit of the
individual noble but it also
enabled such men to dispense
patronage themselves downwards
to their own clients and
retainers.
It enabled them to maintain
their own affinities and
enhanced their standing.
The Tudor kings had no
objection to building up
powerful men of this kind so
long as they were loyal.
But ideally patronage should be
spread around;
it should be dispensed
judiciously in a way that would
maximize the community of
interest in obeying the crown.
Let's look now at consultation.
The royal court was the very
center of the patronage system.
Access to the king was vital,
and those who could control
access to the king were in
positions of real power.
Under the young Henry VIII,
the gentlemen of the privy
chamber,
his personal companions,
those who hunted and engaged in
other sports with the king,
were absolutely central figures
in gaining access to the king,
principal amongst them the
groom of the stool,
an office which still exists.
In Henry's day the groom of the
stool literally looked after the
king's chamber pot and brought
it for him when it was needed.
These were people in an
excellent position to drop names
into the king's ear.
But the court was also vital to
the business of consultation
more broadly.
Any person of significance was
expected to visit the court from
time to time,
and when they were there the
king could be quite
approachable.
Henry VII was quite famously
He let people pop into the
privy chamber where he conducted
business.
Henry VIII was famously
affable, something of a
back-slapping hearty type when
he was in a good mood.
Nobles in particular expected
that kind of personal access.
They expected to be able to
give their counsel informally on
matters of concern.
They weren't part of the
regular executive,
their main duties lay out in
their countries,
but they did expect to visit
for part of the year and have
that kind of personal contact.
More broadly,
the regular executive council
was a point of contact with
these members of the political
nation.
It received letters and
dispatched them.
It expressed the king's
gracious thanks for good
service.
It handled all kinds of
business brought to its
attention.
And then of course there was
Parliament, the greatest
occasion of consultation;
the whole political nation
gathered in common action.
Sir Thomas Smith said that
"every Englishman is
intended to be there present,
either in person or by...
attorney from the prince...
to the lowest person...
And the consent of the
Parliament is taken to be every
man's consent."
The king, however,
only called Parliament when he
needed money or new laws or
support.
Before 1529,
the early Tudors called it only
occasionally,
but then from 1529 to 1559 in
the crisis of the Reformation
there were only eight years
without a parliamentary session
and it grew in significance as a
regular part of the political
process.
The Tudor kings usually got
what they wanted from parliament
but they did it by managing it
carefully.
Its compliance could never be
simply taken for granted.
It had to be managed,
and it was a genuine forum of
debate.
The Speaker of the House of
Commons,
who controlled the agenda,
was granted at the beginning of
each session the liberty of free
speech,
so that he could speak openly
to the king,
and by 1547 that liberty had
been extended to every member of
Parliament within the precincts
of the meetings of Parliament.
They could address any issue
openly for the good of the
prince and the commonwealth.
And these members in their turn
got what they wanted.
Government bills might be
amended in the light of their
local experience and a great
deal of private legislation
intended for particular
localities was passed.
So, Parliament as a place of
consultation was a very
significant forum for the
resolution of potential
conflict,
for the presenting of royal
policy and its explanation and
justification.
The Tudors used it very
carefully to achieve their ends.
In fact, on one occasion Henry
VIII flattered it by saying that
his royal dignity was never so
high as when he met with
Parliament.
And the growing significance of
this institution is indicated by
the anxiety of members of the
governing elite to serve as
members.
But finally,
if propaganda,
the use of patronage and
consultation didn't succeed in
welding together the interests
of the crown and the political
nation,
there remained coercion,
what was described at the time
as heavy lordship,
as distinct from good
lordship--often evident under
both Henry VII and Henry VIII as
they established their authority
and their dynasty.
When necessary they would bring
to Parliament and rush through
'acts of attainder'.
Acts of attainder simply
declared particular individuals
guilty of treason,
depriving them of their lands
and their status.
They were often used against
rebellious nobles.
They could be reversed in the
interests of the heirs to those
estates if they behaved
themselves, but they had to
prove themselves compliant.
Henry VII made frequent use of
acts of attainder.
He very cleverly dated the
beginning of his reign to the
day before the Battle of
Bosworth.
He got Parliament to agree to
that.
That meant that everyone who
had opposed him,
even though they were actually
fighting for the person who was
the king at the time,
was automatically a traitor and
their lands were forfeit.
Clever.
It enabled him to greatly
extend the royal lands in one
move and there was more of that
to come.
Acts of attainder were also
used against those who supported
pretenders to the throne who
were foci of potential
rebellions,
and actual rebellion in 1487
against Henry VII.
Henry VII was also willing to
use another coercive measure,
the placing of his nobility
under recognizances:
recognizance bonds.
They were like a bail bond,
a bond--
a legal bond--that nobles were
forced to enter into to be of
good behavior,
or if they failed to pay
enormous financial penalties.
They usually had to find
sureties from amongst their
kinsmen and supporters for those
bonds,
which meant that those people
had an interest in making sure
that the nobleman concerned
complied and would lose out
themselves badly if he didn't.
These were used,
for example,
against any nobleman who in any
way infringed the requirements
of new laws.
For example,
under Henry VII retaining,
the retaining of an affinity of
clients, was regulated by
license.
Only those who were licensed to
do so could retain armed
retainers and they were
forbidden from retaining any
member of the crown's own
affinity.
You could owe loyalty to the
king only.
Anyone who infringed that was
likely to find himself hauled
before the council and faced
with a recognizance bond.
Lord Abergavenny,
the principal magnate in Kent,
was put under a potential fine
of 70,000 pounds,
a massive sum of money,
for such failure to comply.
It wasn't actually executed but
it hung over his head like the
sword of Damocles and he
complied in future.
And then there were the laws of
treason.
In the fourteenth century the
law of treason had been
introduced defining treason as
acts against the king's person
or his family or open rebellion
against his authority.
Under the early Tudors the law
of treason was extended.
By the time of Henry VIII,
it came to include even
treasonable words such as,
for example,
denying the legitimacy of the
king's many marriages.
Particularly dangerous
individuals were ruthlessly
eliminated.
Under Henry VII,
the young Earl of Warwick--
Edward, Earl of Warwick--who
was the last potential claimant
to the Yorkist claim to the
throne,
was imprisoned in the Tower of
London from childhood where he
was kept until 1499 when in a
moment of danger to the throne
Henry VII had him executed.
Sir William Stanley,
one of those who had supported
Henry at the Battle of Bosworth,
fell under the king's suspicion
and was taken out in 1497.
Under the young Henry VIII,
the presumptuous Edward
Stafford, Duke of Buckingham,
was executed on trumped-up
charges in 1521.
His real crime was that he had
a distant claim to the throne.
Henry didn't yet have a male
heir and it was alleged that
Buckingham had listened to
prophecies that Henry never
would have a male heir,
and that he had made some
resentful statements against the
King.
When this came to the King's
knowledge Buckingham's days were
numbered.
Like most nobles who fell under
royal displeasure,
Buckingham died by the ax.
Lesser folk were hung,
drawn and quartered,
a less honorable means of
execution.
It meant that they were hung by
the neck until they were not
quite dead,
disemboweled,
their bowels burned before
their eyes,
and then cut down,
their bodies cut into four
quarters which were dipped in
pitch and sent to be displayed
at the gates of the leading
cities of the kingdom as an
example to warn other potential
traitors.
And trial procedures and
treason trials could be
extremely arbitrary.
The council could order arrest
at will.
It could order the torture of
suspects--torture wasn't
normally used in English law.
Defense counsel was denied.
Evidence could be fabricated to
get rid of unsuccessful losers
in court factional struggles.
At the very highest levels,
then, political conflict was
played out to the death,
especially under Henry VIII.
Indeed, one historian of Henry
VIII has said that in some parts
of his reign his court had the
atmosphere of the Kremlin under
Stalin,
with people going in constant
fear of arousing the King's
displeasure.
So the crown could deliver
largesse to the loyal;
it could consult with its
leading subjects;
but it could also brutally
display its wrath.
The majesty which it displayed
on the one hand was
counterbalanced by terror.
All of this adds up then to a
political culture,
a set of institutions of
government animated by certain
understandings and rules and
practices which governed
political conduct.
That unwritten consensus about
how things were done was very
well understood throughout
political society,
and political stability
depended upon sharing power in
varying degrees at various
levels of the structure in
accordance with these
understandings.
Effective rule was the outcome
of the use of considerable
political skills by the kings
and their advisers within this
framework to bring about the
willing obedience and
participation of their leading
subjects.
And for the most part the early
Tudor kings proved very able in
achieving that:
in rebuilding the authority of
the crown which had been so much
shaken by the civil wars of the
fifteenth century,
in instilling habits of
obedience, in reestablishing the
latent power of the monarchy and
indeed in enhancing it--
something that we'll discuss in
section.
But finally,
changing government in the
sixteenth century involved more
than just reasserting royal
authority.
It also came to involve
something else,
the expansion of the very scope
and objectives of government,
and to understand that we need
to see its development in the
context of processes of change,
which were scarcely on the
agenda as late as 1530,
but which were very soon to
emerge.
And in the next few lectures
I'll be looking at those by
examining the most explosive of
these new issues,
the issues of the succession
and the issue of religion.